[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my mandalorian episode 3
video
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs
probably one of the best episodes of the
season there's only been three episodes
so it's hard to say there's not a big
sample size
but it's definitely my favorite episode
so far so we'll break it all down all
the easter eggs if you're new to the
channel i'm doing videos for all the
episodes this season
be sure to subscribe to get everything
we're doing a new star wars merch
giveaway
yes there will be baby yoda merch soon
so i'll explain that at the end of the
video
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet obviously we'll
do top 10 wtf and easter eggs as we go
along starting with number 10
the title of the episode is the sin it's
a reference to a couple different story
lines during the episode
to the mandalorians sin of initially
leaving baby yoda this helpless creature
with the imperials in exchange for this
giant fortune in bheskar
it's also a reference to his sin against
the code of the bounty hunter's guild
when he reneges on that agreement to
save baby yoda
later in the episode because now he's
the most wanted man in the sector
along with baby yoda think about it this
way if they activated all those tracking
bops at the end of the episode
it's only going to get worse for him
through the rest of the season while
he's on the run
trying to protect baby yoda but right
after they come out of hyperspace baby
yoda jumps out of his bassinet and grabs
the ball on top of what looks like the
hyperspace lever that's very similar to
the hyperspace lever on the millennium
falcon just to play with it stick it in
his mouth
they carry that moment forward when the
mandalorian goes to activate the lever
later
and sees that the ball is still missing
reminding him of the kid before he goes
back to save him
and then again at the end of the episode
when they pay it off when he detaches
the ball himself
and gives it back to baby yoda to play
with number nine turning over the kid
and collecting his fortune
so the surface of the planet actually
looks really harsh all those red lines
give it a very mustafar
feel like the planet's surface is very
very harsh although i'm pretty sure this
is not mustafar
the actual mustafar planet is way more
red overall in color
the look of the kids face as they're
walking through the shipyards in the
streets seems like he's never been
around
so many people and aliens in a city like
this before and he's having this tiny
little panic attack while he's just not
sure what to make of everything
they pass the same street food vendor
cooking salacious crumbs on his spit
you see way more different classic
aliens you see a twilight for the first
time that they later reference when they
say twilight bath houses when grief
cargo is telling him hey let's go to the
spa it'll be a great time
making it sound like it's more of a
brothel than an actual spa
there's an r5 looking droid that's
colored similarly to the r5 droid the
jawas tried to sell to owen and baru
lars and luke skywalker during a new
hope
that later comes back at the end of the
episode when it's trying to take them to
the shipyards before it gets blown up by
grief karga
things start to turn the minute he sees
how the stormtroopers are treating baby
yoda just yanking him around
trying to poke him like it's a piece of
meat even the stormtrooper who yells at
him for questioning him
sounds exactly like the voice of the
imperial officer during return of the
jedi
that says you rebel scum i wouldn't be
surprised if they actually did try to
sample that voice from the original
trilogy because they do that a lot with
audio easter eggs
it is one of the most iconic imperial
lines from that movie that people repeat
as dr purging and werner herzog's
character scan the baby and get really
excited
they give him his bounty in best car but
when he pulls it out it's the actual ice
cream maker star wars easter egg from
empire strikes back
if you didn't spot it or you're
relatively new to the original trilogy
movies
when they're in cloud city and things
start to go crazy you see this character
running in the background
with what looks like a giant ice cream
maker as fans dubbed it people just
started calling it the star wars ice
cream maker
john favreau brought it back for this
series during empire strikes back nobody
knew
what it was for but on this series john
favreau has turned it into sort of a
portable lockbox for valuables
as he starts to question their
intentions things start to get ugly
werner herzog's character questions his
code quote unquote of honor as a bounty
hunter isn't this against the code of
your guild
he also reminds him that most of his
people the other mandalorians were
killed during the purge
implying that he might join them if he
doesn't get out quickly
so number eight the mandalorian enclave
their codes his new armor and the
cygnets
mandalorians have their own code about
right and wrong that's way more
important to them than any local laws or
any of the laws of other organizations
like the bounty hunters guild this is
the way is the line of dialogue that
they repeat to each other throughout the
episode and then again at the end of the
episode
this is the way but he gets his shiny
new best scar
armor so everybody kind of hates him
because he looks so awesome now
the other mandalorians are really
excited to see what's going on they're
really curious but also really
upset when they see the imperial signets
on the bars these bars were stolen
during the purge
he gets the special new whistling birds
weapon for his gauntlet he used a bunch
of cool weapons during the episode
but it's just guided best guard darts
that detonate on impact
they show you a ton more flashbacks to
the clone wars around episode 2 attack
of the clones you finally see the larger
battle droids in the droid gunship
flying overhead so it's just implying
that this was happening during the clone
wars
and you finally find out why he hates
droids so much in present day because
the battle droids killed his parents
but number seven when the other
mandalorians get pissed at him
for working with the imperials and the
idea that they're just reclaiming
best guard that was stolen from them
during the purge the mandalorian
in the heavy infantrymen armor that
starts to fight with him
is actually voiced by john favreau
himself
if you ever watched any of the clone
wars you probably remember that john
favreau
played the pre-vizsla mandalorian
character one of the most important and
powerful mandalorians around that era
his family descended from the very first
mandalorian to become a jedi and that
mandalorian created a dark saber
thousands of years ago many years later
after he passed away
pre-vizsla's family stole the dark saber
back from the jedi temple and used it as
a symbol to rally the mandalorian clans
together
after they'd been scattered for years
after the great sith war with the jedi
the darksaber is still around in star
wars canon the last time it was seen was
on star wars rebels before the events of
a new hope being wielded by boca tan
crees
one of the last known leaders of the
mandalorian people but as they imply
several times through the series under
imperial rule their people were also
purged kind of like the jedi were during
order 66
in the clans have just scattered to the
four corners of the galaxy
but the signet that they offer him for
his armor is for the mud mudhorn you're
allowed to wear the signet of whatever
you defeat in combat on your armor but
he foregoes it
per the terms of their codes of honor
because baby yoda helped him defeat it
which they sort of incorporate with his
arc during the episode about saving the
kid turning the kid over then changing
his mind
because he says my enemy helped me
defeat it so i'm not allowed to take
credit for the kill
my enemy did not know he was my enemy
when he was helping me
he's talking about baby yoda at this
point is still his enemy because he was
part of the bounty but obviously he
changes his mind at the end of the
episode
per the mandalorians code of honor
number six
all the other bounty hunters of the
guild hate him he almost takes off to
the other side of the galaxy just to
avoid having to think about what he just
did
turning the kid over when he gave him
the bounty for the mon calamari saying
it's a nobleman's son who skipped bail
all i could think about was that admiral
akbar's son has turned into a criminal
but i think this is just some sort of
random member of his race some new
character
i believe that admiral akbar's son does
show up during the new star wars trilogy
although admiral akbar himself
was just killed off in the last movie so
during this show
he's technically still an admiral
because this is right after return of
the jedi in the new republic's fleet
they also finally referenced the actual
new republic but mostly the mandalorians
saying that it's a joke to think that
they would care
what the imperials or the remnants of
the empire are doing this far out on a
backwater outer rim territory
it's funny to think that people hated
the empire because they were so terrible
but they also kind of hate the new
republic because they think that the
government
still doesn't care about them even
though it's a completely different group
of people
number five he decides to rescue baby
yoda so he listens in to werner herzog
and dr pershing talking about the kid
after he finds the bassinet in the trash
outside the office
werner herzog is arguing that he won't
be able to protect the doctor much
longer
and to hurry up and get his sample and
be done with it which we later learn is
code for
kill the kid after you get your sample
of his dna like dr pershing says he'd be
dead now if it weren't for me
more on that in a second because dr
pershing survives at the end of the
episode so he's definitely coming back
but watching the mandalorians mow
through the stormtroopers like a
terminator
was totally badass one of my favorite
sequences through the episode so far
it's like darth vader at the end of
rogue one
you know exactly what's going to happen
he's just gonna mow through
all those rebels with his lightsaber him
going around
room to room also kind of reminded me of
star wars dark
forces that old first person shooter
made in the style of doom or wolfenstein
3d
that was such a great game back in the
day in major bonus points for creative
use of grappling hook he had a lot of
really creative kills during these
scenes he's also been a big fan of his
gauntlet flamethrower which he uses to
barbecue one of the stormtroopers i
think he's used it in every single
episode so far
but number four dr perching in the kid
there's an imperial interrogation droid
in the background just like the one from
star wars new hope when darth vader was
interrogating leia in her cell
and just like that scene they zoom in on
the needle
but you also wonder if he was using this
on baby yoda somehow
how do you interrogate a baby they can
barely speak or more likely it was there
in the background and they were using it
for other things on other people
dr purging mistakenly thinks he's there
to kill the kid which lets you know that
even though he's working with the empire
on some sinister cloning project he's
not a total
monster he cares about the well-being of
the kid so maybe he will also turn later
in the series and actually try to help
the mandalorian protect baby yoda
but the device that he hasn't hooked
into that's taking samples is probably
taking dna samples for potential future
cloning
and the episode ends with them implying
that he got all the samples that he
needed so this cloning project can move
forward and it might wind up becoming
something bigger during a future season
if they don't shut it down before the
season finale
maybe dr pershing will help out with
that but the only way to stop something
like that would be to destroy all the
samples or destroy all the research that
they generate
from those samples number three was the
scene of them activating all those fobs
and the bounty hunters from the guild
coming after him again
i love the slow scene of the cantina
with the bounty hunters realizing what's
happening oh wait a minute the bounty's
back on
the scene of him slowly trying to walk
out of town kind of looking around
noticing that all the other bounty
hunters are just waiting to make a move
is this great moment of tension they
have their big standoff
carl weather's grief karga calls him on
the code of the bounty hunter's guild
that he's violated
and just as he's about to go down all
the other mandalorians
jet pack in reigning fire on all them so
number two
john favreau's mandalorian infantryman
leads the charge
as pissed off as he was at the
mandalorian for working with the
imperials earlier in the episode
their code is higher than any other
local law or the bounty hunters guild so
it doesn't matter that they'll have to
move their secret base to another planet
for their protection
this is the way we protect our own so it
doesn't matter what the mandalorian has
done to break the code of the bounty
hunters guild or
break in any kind of imperial or local
laws the mandalorians will rally to help
him no matter what
you get a sense for all the different
types of technology that they use
almost all of them besides the mando
himself have jet packs they sort of pay
that off at the end of the episode with
the funny moment i gotta get myself one
of these as john favreau's mandalorian
jet packs up alongside his ship salutes
him and then goes back down to the
planet
even though this was a huge scene a huge
moment of them all coming together and
fighting and it was probably really
expensive to film i'm hoping that we get
something even bigger like this later in
the season where more
mandalorians rally to help him number
one wtf they escape
but grief karga survives thanks to the
best guard bars
blocking the blaster shot nice used the
carbonite freezing device to steam up
the cargo hold to get him
but because he and the imperials are
still alive werner herzog's character is
still alive dr pershing is still alive
they have the research in the dna
samples from baby yoda things are only
going to get
worse through each episode as the empire
tries to get rid of both of them
the bounty on them will probably go up
they'll become more notorious through
the sector as other bounty hunters from
other planets start to rally to try and
take him down
but we're still not even halfway through
the season we still need to meet gina
carano's bounty hunter character and we
still haven't met giancarlo
esposito's imperial moff character yet
and he's even more powerful and seems
like he's tied to werner herzog's
character and dr perching somehow
as you would expect he's also playing a
very gus fring like character on the
show
but let me know if you spotted any big
easter eggs in the episode that i didn't
mention in my video
obviously my episode 5 video will post
next week i'll do more bonus videos for
the mandalorian during this week too so
if you have any special requests or big
questions you want me to answer just let
me know in the comments
for those of you asking about merch they
did say they would start selling baby
yoda merch really soon so the giveaways
will probably be something for that
stuff once they announce what the actual
merch is going
to be but everyone click here for my new
baby yoda in jedi history video
and click here for my mandalorian
episode 2 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
you